hello grammarians uh today we're going
to be discussing more irregular plurals
so this is the irregular plural part two
the tuning
because we really want to focus on this
n
particle i'll explain in a minute so
previously we discussed the idea that
there's you know one regular plural
and then there are a couple of different
kinds of irregular plurals
so we have the word
dog and it becomes dogs
we have the word
leaf
and it becomes
leaves
i'd like to introduce something else too
the word child
is also an irregular plural because its
plural form is not child's but in fact
you ready say with me
children
whoa that's weird what is that about
like i said english is not a predictable
language few languages are when we think
of english as one solid block of wood
what we're actually seeing is this
lashed together raft made of spit hope
and history
so it's your job as a writer and a
speaker of english to make of this
crooked timber something straight to
borrow a phrase and then mangle it
so the question is what is the deal
right
and the answer is that it has to do with
english language history and heritage
english comes to us from old english
which if you look at it now it kind of
looks like german because english is a
germanic language that's the term
linguists use
so in old english there were a bunch of
different ways to make something plural
you know some some some nouns would
become plural by adding an en some you
could add an s
some you would add an r
and part of this depends on what part of
england you lived in at the time
there were a bunch of different regional
variations
today this en ending only applies to
basically three or four words these are
all you need to remember for this one
weird en thing so the en ending plural
only applies to
child
ox
brother or sister
and even those
these are really rare i bet you don't
even know what i'm talking about the
plural of brother originally was
brethren the plural of sister is sistren
or sustrin
but these are so rare and brothers and
sisters is so common that we don't even
need to consider them so really the only
the only weird en plurals that are going
to be in common usage are children
and oxen
and unless you know your family raises
musk oxen or you're an ox driver you're
probably not going to be using the word
ox very often and if oxen are
a big part of your life you probably
knew how to pluralize them already just
from hearing people talk about them your
entire childhood so i'm going to cross
that off too the only thing you need to
worry about is the en in children
child
becomes
children
now you're probably wondering david you
know if if there's the word ox and ox
becomes oxen
what about box why is the plural of box
boxes and not boxing
to
borrow a gag from brian regan um the
simple truth is that it has to do with
this word's origin
ox is a native old english word box
comes to us originally from greek and
then latin and then french that's how it
came to english
i'm sorry if that's not a very
satisfying answer but that's how english
works english is this language that is
composed of a bunch of different puzzle
pieces all mashed together by time
history and repeated invasions which are
totally metal
but i'm getting away from myself the
important thing to remember is that for
this irregular plural this en ending
really unless you work with oxen um or
unless you are leading some sort of
old-timey folk revival where you have to
refer to brethren and cistern
child to children is really the only
change you need concern yourself with
all this
could be summed up boop just like that
you can learn anything
dave it out
now if you're still with me i would like
to relate a humorous historical anecdote
that comes to us from the 15th century
english printer
william caxton
now this story comes to us from about
the year 1490 and i just want to use
this story to illustrate
just how different how dependent on what
part of the country you were living in
was on the language that you spoke
because before mass transit
and mass communication media which
william caxton was a part of because he
was one of the first english language
printers before any of this technology
allowed us all to communicate with each
other
we basically just had letters and most
people were illiterate and talking to
each other and since it wasn't really
easy to get from place to place to place
before the advent of cars
most people didn't really go very far
so here is the story which i will
translate for you from middle english
goes like this so these merchants were
traveling from the thames river which
flows through london and they're trying
to get to zealand here
which is in the modern day netherlands
this is incidentally this is uh this is
england this is the southern southeast
coast of england they're trying to get
to zealand and this is a distance of
about 160 miles
give or take
but they can't make it there because of
bad winds they stop here at forland to
refresh their stores they stop for
groceries basically and then they
realize that they're london english and
the english of the place where they are
which is maybe 60 miles out of london
maybe
is mutually incomprehensible a man goes
into a house asks the woman of the house
for eggs she doesn't understand the word
eggs because the word she uses for eggs
is aaron
the word egg
is norse and he says i would like some
aegis and she says i don't have any
eggis i don't speak french and he gets
angry because he's like i don't speak
french either i'm english he says do you
have any eggs she says i don't know what
that is and finally someone says i think
he means eren do you have any eren and
she said oh eren of course here buy some
and it just goes to show you that before
the advent of mass communication
we could have had
variations from as caxton put it shire
to shire to shire each little town had
its own variant of language and it
wasn't until everything was united by
this technology that caxton worked with
the printing press that people started
to become literate and converge toward
what we would consider a more unified
standard of english alright that was
just a little bonus silly video you can
learn anything david out